I was saying to uh just to my friends
man I'm you know I cried on my 25th
birthday I cried on my 30th birthday and
on my 35th birthday I was like damn dude
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna actually
live you know what I mean and so just
thinking about you know that Journey
from the time I got drafted to the time
I hit 30 was just it was just a lot
coming back home you know what I mean
having to deal with that you know being
on the road people you know just during
the season people think you saw say
something to you you know you gotta go
find them in off season and see if it's
real oh wow you know what I mean like
just wow you know what I mean and like I
think once I kind of got to go to state
you know things just start kind of like
leveling out I was like man let me
change let me change who I am and and
like I don't need to be this this is not
me you know what I mean I'm not I'm not
like I'm not like this you know I want
to be what do you have to prove like I
didn't have to sit here you know you're
a millionaire you're on TV every day
yeah and at the same time like bro I'm
scared to die yeah
it's real out here you know what I mean
like they they shoot at athlete out here
back in the day crazy right remember
Jalen Rose got shot at um
why are you shooting at Jalen Rose right
who the [__]
shoots at Jalen Rose you know what I
mean and he was on Sunset so that just
you know for me it was just like that
era was a lot of jacking you know it was
a lot of uh pressure extortion you know
the NBA players are getting extorted all
day NBA players rappers uh
musician anybody came to La it was just
not a good place to be you know what I
mean like if you got found or you was
out shopping it like if if you can stay
low cool but back then if you was you
was on the move and you get caught it I
mean you have to have mercy I was gonna
say because I I would like like
obviously a lot of the stuff is highly
back to the camera phones thing we see a
lot more of the people getting robbed on
Sunset or on Melrose and it's like yeah
that kind of [__] has always been
happening in LA but I feel like back in
the day it was really like Peak you kind
of had to come to LA and like
if you were going to move around you
really had to be in line with some guys
to make sure that there wasn't any sort
of yeah yeah that was the whole like uh
the tap in error the tap in error
people's chains were getting took people
had to get the chains yeah you get the
chain back we gotta I mean you know I
got a couple chains back from some for
some uh some rappers actually no
basketball players whose team did you
get
[Laughter]
I just know they one of my favorite you
know one of my favorites uh you know a
couple rappers man just
that's just how I be you know what I
mean like a couple rappers just like
come to LA tickets lost in and you got
to think like coming up in that game
there to air with the game when game was
first starting to like break out like it
was no blood rappers
it was no Bloods famous period you know
what I mean yeah if you really think
outside of Mack 10 yeah it was Mac 10
and then and then the game and then
everybody was a blood everybody started
being Bloods you know what I mean so
imagine like
rocking with the blood that is on his on
his way up you know what I mean in L.A
so it was a lot to deal with with that
and he was the face of La for like a
decade yeah he carried the whole coach
for like a very long time yeah and and I
think it just kind of for me like
hanging with game
made me realize that okay man my plan
was me and gang rocking together I mean
he can unify the music I can unify the
hoop and then we can create this
La unified system where like we can make
it better for dudes you know what I mean
like we can stop
all the jacking and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying like at least if
they [__] with us they rolling with
us we ain't gonna get checked you ain't
gonna get Robbie ain't gonna get into no
funny business you know what I mean and
like that was the goal is really like
once I saw that I was like man like nip
coming Dom coming you know YG had had a
couple songs but YG was on his way you
know what I mean it was a bunch of dudes
just like on a rise and I was like damn
dude uh Kenji you know what I mean Jay
Rock was out but Jay Rock was like on
his way so like uh I remember we did the
gang the Crips and bloods gang
documentary and uh I was like man I need
to put a soundtrack together
and on the soundtrack is all them dudes
like damn their first soundtrack right I
remember how long ago was that
documentary uh I think I want to say 20
2015 not 1204 I think 2004 yeah Jesus
Christ yeah it was like 2004 or when I
got to
yeah it was like 2004.